bonjour à tous je suis soué le tchtech
la semaine dernière nous avons vu
ensemble le rôle de l'armée française
aujourd'hui nous allons parler plus
spécifiquement des missions de l'armée à
la Réunion comment l'armée française
est-elle présente à la réunion
l'ensemble des trois forces armées terre
mer et air est présent à la réunion
depuis plusieurs années déjà ces trois
forces sont regroupées au sein des phoy
qui signifie force armée dans la zone
sud de l'Océan Indien les phasoil
regroupe la Réunion et Mayotte cette
force est composée d'environ 1900
militaires comment sont composé les
trois forces des phasoil l'armée de
terre est composée du 2e RPIMa le
régiment parachutiste d'infanterie de
marine basée à Pierrefond et également
du DLEM le détachement de Légion
étrangère de Mayotte basée à daouzi la
Marine nationale est quant à elle
composée de six navires situés au port
de la rivière des galas dont deux
transportent chacun un hélicoptère
ponire mais elle est également présente
à Mayotte avec deux bâtiments enfin
l'armée de l'air est présente à la
réunion avec le détachement RDA 181
composé d'un escadron de transport
appelé et50 et qui comprend deux avions
de transport C160 plus connus sous le
nom de
Transal ces deux avions seront remplacés
mi-205 par des Casa
cn235 vous n'oubliez pas le RSMA
j'allais y venir le RSM régiment du
service militaire adapté de la Réunion
est dirigé et encadré par du personnel
militaire mais c'est une composante du
ministère de l'outreem et donc du
ministère de l'intérieur ainsi son
budget ne dépend pas du ministère de la
Défense ce régiment porte sa
contribution à l'effort nationale en
faveur de l'insertion des jeunes
réunionnés à la Réunion les effectifs
passeront de 750 jeunes par an à près de
1500 jeunes en 2016 le RSMA ne fait donc
pas partie des phoy alors quelle est la
zone opérationnelle des phoy les phaso
couvre la ZRP zone de responsabilité
permanente de la zone Sud a indien cette
zone comprend la zone maritime sud de
l'Océan Indien avec les départements de
la Réunion et Mayotte les îles pars et
les tafes terre austral et Antarctique
français ainsi que les Comores et les
Séchelles c'est donc une zone fort
étendue quels sont les missions des
forces armées à la Réunion et dans la
zone les Pho exerc différentes missions
bien entendu cell de protéger le
territoire national les installations
stratégiques et contribuer au maintien
de la sécurité elles doent ai assurer la
prévention et la préservation des
intérêts de la France dans la zone de
responsabilité permanente contre toute
forme d'agression extérieure affirmer la
souveraineté française sur ces
territoires terrestres et maritimes
notamment en maintenant une présence
continue sur les îles épars Europa ran
des Nova Bassas des India glorieuse et
Tromelin nos navires de la Marine lutte
ainsi contre les pêches illégales dans
les eaux territoriales françaises et
lors crise sur ces territoires ou à
l'extérieur elles doivent être en mesure
de conduire ou participer à des
opérations militaires et mener des
opérations de secours d'urgence ainsi
les tronsal et nos militaires
participent régulièrement à des
opérations humanitaires lors de
catastrophes naturelles en apportant par
exemple du matériel et des vivres mais
aussi de l'assistance technique les phoy
assure également des missions de
formation et de coopération militaire
avec les p pays ayant des accords de
défense avec la France et d'autres
missions encore les phasoy
participent-elles parfois à des
opérations internationales oui et ce de
manière régulière en effet les phasoy
participe notamment depuis 2009 à la
mission Atalante cette mission lutte
avec une quinzaine d'autres pays
européens contre la piraterie au large
des côtes de la Somalie la mission sera
prolongée au moins jusqu'au 12 décembre
2016 j'espère que la présence et les
missions des forces armées françaises à
la Réunion n'ont plus de secret pour
vous et que vous leur ferez bon accueil
à bientôt pour un nouvel
épisode y